welcome back to Las Vegas now we are
kick starting our weekend with the
perfect comfort meal
chef nanny bubby is showing us how to
make ricotta meatballs let's check it
out
hi everyone welcome to Danny bubbies
kitchen still not the studio no I miss
all you guys can't wait to get back of
course we always want to thank Chapman
for sponsoring our segment
Melissa foods for always providing our
produce and we are happy to be with you
to give you a recipe and ricotta
meatballs better known as gluten-free
meatballs but they're so delicious you
don't need to tell them they're
gluten-free we're pairing it with some
pasta and you may say why do you want to
show Lewton free meatballs if you're
making it with pasta pasta that has
plenty of gluten in it and that's
because you always have to remember no
matter who comes through your door you
always have to feed them and you never
know you can or can't have one so we're
going to start with two pounds of meat
and you can use any kind of meat that
you like but I prefer to use dark meat
turkey and also chicken hot Italian
sausage start by mixing this and you're
going to add to it two tablespoons of
chopped parsley about two and a half
cloves of garlic you may use more or
less depending on your garlic taste
we're gonna put in half a cup of
Parmesan cheese now normally they say
not to put Parmesan cheese and meatballs
because it drives them out but when
you're using the ricotta cheese you
really want the parmesan in there
because it helps dry it out just a
little bit then of course we're going to
use two tablespoons of basil again you
put your biggest live on the outside
leave on the outside roll it up like a
cigar make sure it's nice and dry you
chop away look at that okay that's about
two tablespoons
we're gonna throw it in can't get
injured on the job here Marlon we're
going to use about what didn't have cups
of ricotta cheese which is about an
entire container but this is what we'll
do with it I'm going to take this put it
into a sieve over a glass bowl and
you're going to stick it in the
refrigerator for about two hours or more
I already done this and you can see that
what I have here is one only drained and
you want to drain it because you don't
want extra water in this to make it way
too moist so you can see look at what
that did right you don't worry pasta so
we're gonna take that put that right in
here love that and then we're going to
take three eggs that have been brought
to room temperature in the shower we're
going to mix these up like lightly mix
into the ball and then one fabulous in
the ingredient which is knit isn't that
amazing but yes the mint is the secret
ingredient in this recipe mix it lightly
with your fork you don't want to mix it
too hard and over mix it because even
your meatballs become very tough and
we're gonna add about a teaspoon and a
half of salt there we go perfect and
into the refrigerator for 30 minutes
just so it get firm up a little bit so
the key to making perfect meatballs is
using an ice cream scoop
go figure I thought ice cream scoops
were only for ice cream but watch how
these make perfectly sized nut balls
give them a little bit of a rub they are
very yeah look at that
quite loose because they were cottage
cheese okay ready to stick them in the
oven there we go 350 degrees for 20 to
25 minutes into our Chapman oven and
here they are the ricotta meatballs in a
light marinara sauce all ready to serve
they are definitely the star of this
meal co-starring grilled eggplant and
zucchini just very light with a little
bit of French sea salt on it midnight
pasta it is so easy to make and let me
tell you I actually handmade this pasta
myself with my pasta maker it is so much
easier than you think so tune in and two
weeks from now and I will show you how
easy it is to make this kind of pasta
and of course this is my favorite
Italian sustainable wine and it's
Italian and sustainable just like my
husband don't you know it let's give
this a taste remember you can find all
of these things on chef nanny Bubbe calm
deep slash game-changers let's see how
this is
mmm some light oh so much flavor so
delicious enjoy everybody check out chef
nanny Bubbe on Facebook and Instagram
and thank you did you have an automotive
for sponsoring the segment